you know thinking about
digital currency in general like digital
finance
it's a one of the big transitions
transformations
of our world in some sense it's not just
about money
or you could argue that money is
everything i mean it's like
money isn't just the the narrow
definition of money money is really
everything and so we're
you could argue that sort of uh
cryptocurrency
is like the base layer of this
transformation to the digital space and
everything else will just be
built on top of it i use a different
word um
that i think is kind of closer to your
uh world which is
it's ultimately automation and what i
mean by that is
uh you know before 1970 or 1980 all the
assets were analog
and so when you have analog assets
physical stock certificates physical
bonds right physical
deed to a home uh you have to physically
exchange them yeah
when we wanted to increase transactions
and increase kind of global finance and
access
we took those physical assets and we
created electronic qsip assets so now we
have in centralized databases kind of a
file
represents the asset that's sitting
somewhere in custody and you and i can
transact them a little bit easier but
still centralized there's still some
bureaucracy
and you know maybe it takes two days to
transact rather than actually mailing it
across the other world
now what we're seeing is a transition
from those electronic q subs to these
digital assets
and so if you look at again just let's
say money uh or currency
every currency in the world is going to
be digital you're gonna have a digital
dollar
a digital euro yen rmb you're gonna have
decentralized uh kind of open source uh
money like bitcoin you're also gonna
have private currencies
like facebook's attempt at dm uh and
there will be others that will try to do
this
and so when you get everything digital
right i think that's the kind of first
step everyone focuses on
the competition at the technology layer
essentially goes away
you get some level of feature parity and
sure there's bells and whistles on each
kind of implementation of a digital
currency
but at the end of the day the technology
is relatively the same
and ultimately what it will do is it
will facilitate the adoption of
digital wallets so you have to have a
digital wallet regardless of what
digital currency you have
same with me same with everybody else in
the world but what it does do is when
you
kind of uh push away and reduce the
friction of competition
at the technology layer it moves the
competition to the monetary policy layer
and so when you get to that layer now it
becomes interesting because all of the
currencies are the same
except for this one right now and maybe
there will be others in the future
uh but but for sure bitcoin today and
people may try to replicate in a private
manner or something but bitcoin is kind
of the the only
finite scarce digital cell money and so
when you then have that pretty big
difference in that competition at the
monetary policy layer
it's actually not going to matter where
you get paid
right and what i mean by that is like
you and i both live in a single currency
environment i get paid in dollars
i historically have saved in dollars all
of the assets in my life
are denominated in dollars and i owe
my debts in dollars whether it's taxes
or in the private market
and i don't have to worry about foreign
currencies i don't exchange anything
the only time i would ever think about
another currency is if i'm going to
another country
in their single currency environment and
in order to
change or exchange my currency i go to
the bank
or go get ripped off at the airport like
those are my two options it was high
friction
to change between currencies when the
competition
of technology is kind of um innovated
away
now i can get paid in dollars these
digital dollars and with a click of a
button switching to any other currency
in the world
and so what ultimately happens is value
and liquidity is going to coalesce
around the best monetary policy and so
you get in this very weird world where
even if the united states says hey
you're gonna get paid in dollars
you have to pay your taxes in dollars
you're gonna start to see people operate
in a multi-currency environment where
they say okay i got paid in my digital
dollar click a button i save in bitcoin
it stays there protects or grows my
purchasing power oh i need to pay my
taxes let me switch back into dollars
with click of a button and pay
when you go to a multi-currency world
it's not just about currency
it's now multi-asset world because not
only is the
currency digitized but that same
technology is used to digitize
stocks bonds and commodities as well and
so
today we live in a very fragmented
financial world where basically i have a
brokerage account
i have a bank account i may have an
alternative asset account etc
when i can put all those assets in a
single digital wallet
and i can then go from asset to asset
without having to go back to a single
unit of
account like frictionless uh going but
from acid to asset
yeah so now what you end up doing is you
start to open up the possibility for
machine to machine transactions
yeah so today if you and i write
software code for two machines to
transact with each other
yeah they can't transact physical
currency and in many cases they can't
actually transact the electronic qsip
currencies or assets either
because there's too long of a settlement
time so you can't get true automation
right so the whole idea of like the
car's gonna drive over a strip in the
road it's gonna pay the toll
right well that can't happen right now
because literally the transaction won't
go through
right and so i always joke that like in
an automated world
it's like a cd-rom but we're trying to
take cassette tape player assets and put
in the cd-rom
it's just incompatible technology
references nobody understands at this
point
by the way you need to update your
references i probably do it's like
taking a cd-rom trying to put an mp3
player
into uh streaming but but i think that
the reason why that becomes really
interesting is when you start to create
these digital assets
now you open up the world of
possibilities so when new technology is
created you can do two things you can
either create new things the world's
never seen before
or you can use it to improve the old
world most people because it's the
easiest thing to think about
want to improve the old world so an
equivalent of this would be
when the internet came along a media
company that had newspapers
would say hey we should take a pdf of
the newspaper and we should put it on a
website
and now anyone in the world can go to
this website they can read the newspaper
today
that was valuable but it missed out on
the ability to change headlines
to test to put multimedia to distribute
it differently
to you know do all kinds of things that
today we understand the internet really
empowered
and so what i think we're about to watch
happen is we're going to digitize the
assets
we're going to put them all into these
digital wallets you're going to get
automated
technologies where machines cannot
transact with each other and
we're gonna do simple things like why do
we pay
people once every two weeks why don't we
just pay them at the end of every day
or why don't i literally stream payments
to you yeah on an hour-by-hour basis
based on the work you do
it would solve incredible economic
issues in our country and in countries
around the world
but historically businesses can't do
this because the technology problem
they can't keep track of it all how do
they pay everyone every day how do they
pay everyone every hour like
you just can't do it yeah it's funny the
the the vision of the future you're
painting
it's kind of an exciting one and it
almost makes me sad
looking into the future when we'll look
back at this time it's like
is how incredibly inefficient
of financial transactions were like the
transaction of value of any kind
like how like what to pay each other
like there has to like processes there's
like
payroll and all this kind of just the
the entirety of the transactions
is just like painful almost all
transactions are painful
and even and the companies that innovate
to make the transactions a little bit
more frictionless like amazon with one
click purchase button
like went out huge but even that's
really painful
so it's actually really interesting
especially when you start to move that
into the space of data
there's a lot of people thinking about
privacy and data and like can we put
can we uh like convert data into
like money it's just so that you can pay
for how much you reveal to the companies
about your own private data that can
then be
used to assign value to you so you can
use a service for free
if you hand over the data but there's
like explicit transaction going on
so you can empower all those kinds of
things
that uh will just like fundamentally
change our world that's that's really
really really exciting
one of one of the most interesting
things to me um is i invested in a
company called bridget what they told me
was they said eight billion dollars
was paid to the top four banks last year
on overdraft fees okay so literally they
took eight billion dollars from people
who didn't have money in their bank
account
right and so when you dig into why is
that a lot of times it's not that the
people don't have the money
it's actually a mismatch of the payments
yeah so what ends up happening is you
get paid on the first and the 15th
but on the 12th your netflix bill hits
on the 13th you went grocery shopping
and on the 14th your car payments hit
you over draft and then on the 15th you
actually get the check and then you're
able to pay not only the overdraft but
for the
expenses that you have and so something
as simple as just getting paid at the
end of every day
immediately would eliminate you know
some big percentage of those eight
billion dollars of value that flows to
large institutions on overdraft fees
yeah and also i mean this whole process
with
overdraft fees and just many of the
financial transactions we have to live
through today
forces many of us to be like accountants
like to understand uh the different
mechanism of financial like the movement
of money
as opposed to you which is what we want
to do as human beings
operating in higher layers of like
providing services for others
of like following your passions and like
working for
others like doing cool [ __ ] or or you
know
basically providing value exchanging
value in the world and not thinking
about the money
the money takes care of itself and then
you see the results of it so you're
you're able to think in terms of
money but not have to know
how the like the accounting works
automation
simply frees humans up to do more
creative work yeah
right yeah like that like that's it yeah
and which is why they use the term
which is why you use the term automation
which i think is kind of brilliant uh
reframing of all this yeah because
ultimately digital technologies
are merely the conduit to usher us into
that world
yeah and i think the most fascinating
part of this entire industry is
people who are trying to figure out now
that we're going to have these digital
technologies
how do we usher in that automated world
faster
and so there's people who are building
all kinds of incredible things right
there's literally
um some technologies where you can
stream uh for paying for consumption of
content
yeah right there's i saw somebody
recently who they basically said hey
i have created something but it's not
going to be released
until everyone almost like a gofundme
type
situation pays for in combination then
it gets unlocked
and so when you start to think about
this it's not only innovation on the
technology front it's innovation around
the way that we form uh capital it's the
way that we
organize resources it's the way that we
build companies it's the business models
right it's the application of those
technologies
all that stuff starts to change and go
back
to what 20 uh 2007 is when the iphone
came out uber wasn't possible right he's
going online like all these companies
that weren't possible before
when the digital technologies are kind
of adopted on a global scale
i think that we all myself included
drastically underestimate how
fast and how big innovation can be uh
because it's just hard
right like like we like to think
linearly and that's not how the world
works
you